hello reject nation we are going to
watch the official trailer for the
matrix rebooted aka the matrix
resurrections koi john drew
uh that's how johnny
with us today woke up at 4 30 in the
morning to drive all the way over here
thank you for being here please follow
this man on his youtube channel not only
is he a big fan of comics like you can
tell just from his segments with comic
book shopping where he had yaya abdul
mateen ii on there as well we mentioned
the matrix before we were supposed to
wow follow him on youtube he's almost at
10k followers and then last time he was
over we talked heavily about the matrix
and apparently like like myself it is
one of his favorite movies of all time
too ever there is no spoon and we got
trinity here with us today i am so
excited you have no idea you have no
clue how excited i am i'm ready to
absorb this trailer let's get into it
people please as always if you can go
and hit that like button it helps us out
on the algorithm significantly but yeah
let's let's watch this let's watch this
hey guys so the music in here actually
got us a copyright claim uh obviously
had to remove it
but still watch the reaction and we
talked for so long afterwards we got
plenty of thoughts on this so i really
hope you just stick around
thomas
you seem particularly triggered right
now
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
wow
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
the wallpaper in the background
everything
it's the colors are so saturated too
[Music]
oh whoa
blue pill well three blue pills
fascinating
oh wow
[Laughter]
is it literally reading alice in
wonderland yeah
templating
it's like an old guy yeah
take that red pill man remember if you
want the truth yeah follow the white
rabbit you're going to have to fall on
me
oh you're gonna meet the
architect the only thing that matters to
you is still here
i know it's why you're still fighting
and why you will never give up
oh
you don't know me
no
there we go
there we go
wow
damn
damn agents
oh
[Music]
yeah he looked like an agent
oh
stopping the bullets
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
[Laughter]
hell yeah dude hearing that sound again
hearing that
new visuals
oh man i that was better than i hoped
that was great that was more than i
hoped all right so we watched this again
uh just now i mean first off i'm loving
the fact of how different it looks they
don't have the same returning
cinematographer it's only lana which
housekey returning this time around so
naturally there's going to be some
things about it aesthetically production
design-wise that are going to look and
feel a little bit different i'm enjoying
the plot the way it seems to be
unveiling itself from the looks of it it
seems like neo
or thomas anderson this time around
again the blue pill is literally
a form of repressing his memory that's
what it seems to be honing in on like
he's got his therapist i feel like
that's something maybe the machines or
whatever have set up for him to repress
his memories of it and it seems like a
lot of what we're seeing in the trailer
especially with saying he's having
dreams are like memories of the first
three matrix films and he's being forced
to push that aside so it looks like to
me that the matrix itself has actually
been obviously it's been
rebooted one point you did see a shot of
what looked like trinity back in that
like birthing human tube so i don't
really know maybe they've um
like i get the arrest forever about this
we could be here for an hour i'm trying
to be trying to summarize this without
so over overtaking the entire
conversation here i would imagine that
they have somehow either duplicated
their bodies since the machines do grow
the human bodies as established in the
first matrix movie or somehow they have
managed to preserve their bodies from
the previous matrix movie i would say
like maybe that's the case for neo and
they kept the program alive within him
yeah koi what do you think is going on
with yaya doing teams
morpheus he's probably want us to think
he's young morpheus they gave us every
bit of morpheus we could possibly
morpheus but i think it's a mislead i
think
is meant to be like the guy is the most
morpheous vibes one could have
got himself but there are some
interesting moments in the trailer where
i think he might be working in
duplicitous working for the matrix as a
as a morpheus type what if he's the
matrix's morpheus what if he's meant to
make us think he's someone to trust the
red pill actually puts them deeper into
the matrix what if the the we have all
these prior connotations what the matrix
is what if he actually breaks our
reality further by putting him doing a
deeper like software level because i
think the whole idea of the matrix works
today because we've all become the
architect like when the internet was
born we created constructs that are
individual characters avatars so in
reality post 1999 when the first matrix
came out we've become our own architects
of creating these characters so if the
matrix is going to be as timely as it
was in 1999 they're gonna have to update
it to the internet world which is all of
these new birthing concepts which i
think include yaya okay
john
say something
i loved a lot of the color choices it
looks like the matrix but also very much
updated and and more lush in terms of
just its color palettes you had a lot of
very symbolic uses of blue which is why
like yeah the therapist it totally
tracks that he would be probably an
agent of the matrix keeping neo
repressed and suppressed because look at
those blue glasses frames then again i'm
like that girl has blue hair though with
the white rabbit so what yes yeah what's
the significance and how are they going
to use the pills because those are even
on the poster so i wonder if they're
going to play with that motif directly
but just took me by a great amount of
surprise in terms of it doesn't look
like we're just picking up where the
last one left off and throwing a bunch
of familiar matrix tropes at you like
there are those things in here this
looks like its own movie and a fresh you
know iteration of the matrix which was
the most exciting aspect well i mean it
was something that it seems i'm sorry
did you guys also notice the young a
seemingly young
yaya asmorphia shot where it looks like
he's looking into the mirror what if
that was them corrupting young morpheus
so that when neo meets him he assumes to
trust him but like we've got a past
tense maybe a early beta version of
morpheus that would be inherently
trusted by yes actually under control of
them because he looked as confused as we
were i think you're onto something there
because there was this one shot in the
trailer where it looked like when neo
was looking in the mirror there was like
an old version of himself mm-hmm like
there's a time element here so i imagine
like okay because as we know the world
of the matrix is different than the the
real world like zion and such i'm
wondering if residual self-image because
he looks like a younger like he could be
perhaps a younger morpheus just within
the program and yes the lawrence
fishburne outside could be you know like
really old
or something did you ever see the
birthing moment of trinity in the
original no no we do so that could be an
element that's actually from the past
because we don't know if the chronology
is there that could be a shot of her in
the first film chronologically being
birthed that is a mislead here for the
trailer and they're all actually older
we've got larry fishburne actually has
more guys outside etc well what i'm
liking that we're seeing with the
trailer itself it seems to be playing a
lot more into just actual
psychology you know like it's a lot of
it's very much you know
like on the nose about it he's literally
in therapy right here but in the way how
a lot of the visuals are being recreated
it is like trauma it seems like neo's
past with the previous matrix films are
serving as a form of trauma for the guy
he seems very lonely and isolated and
haunted by all these things and it's
sort of being treated like ptsd what
he's suffering from having to take
medication for all that but literally
like the way how in real life when we're
traumatized we recreate so it looks like
that this is working on many levels
resurrection literally an actual reboot
that will be a little self-aware about
that recreation the way how trauma works
but looks like he's coming into his own
element again we're becoming you know
the one once again but you see these
shots of trinity in here and she was
doing like some very like powers we've
never seen trinity do before so i i
imagine she'll be some other type of i
don't know enhanced anomaly of sorts
yeah remember than the third film when
there was that rebirth i imagine that
would change someone's programming so if
she was reborn in in zion in our world i
imagine that would change how she's
reinducted into the matrix itself and if
this is in order of chronology in that
scene her in the fourth film just like
neo would have had to evolve to be back
in the matrix so i think she might have
an awakening of her own a la thomas
anderson in the first film and that like
cause uh a new array of powers maybe
maybe i mean she's like whatever that
power is and then they're like they're
jumping off of the roof together at the
end i'm like is neo going to take her
flying or they're gonna go to the fly
yeah they're gonna fly together right
they're gonna make it
it looks like she has like powers that
are way more exceeded than the first one
so and like those fight scenes the two
of them bullet time and gimme yeah
and missile timing yeah
and what you were bringing up about blue
or girl that's jessica henwick uh from
iron fist game of thrones oh
and i know she's almost unrecognizable
she was in the teaser trailer i was like
who is playing a character named i think
rumored to be playing a character named
bugs who is ser who is serving as a uh
you know like uh the trinity uh
essentially from the first matrix movie
at least that's what it looks apparently
like yeah do you guys feel like it's
very intentional the smith uh the agents
aren't back that we're used to because i
do feel like this is later on in the
programming so them being destroyed is
actually going to hold true what do you
guys think about the agents i mean we
saw the agent we saw one agent that made
it clear here what i'm more focused on
in terms of agents is that one shot okay
but that there was that one shot but
also
you got neil patrick harris and jonathan
groff jonathan graf from mine hunter and
frozen yeah so you guys think you're
frozen in the matrix
so you have jonathan uh graff here and i
feel like neil patrick harris is
probably all right maybe a program um
but
uh i think jonathan groff is probably
the bad guy i feel like he yeah he's
definitely got that aura he's got a bit
of an agent vibe about him but like a
more subtle one he's not just out there
mr anderson yeah yeah exactly i i do
think he's got program neil patrick
harris is a program i think there's
gonna be a mislead with yaya where he is
good inherently good but he's doing
things because he's been reprogrammed
maybe at a younger age and that'll get
come into play yeah i think maybe
there's some elements with cipher i
don't know if they're going to
incorporate what it's like to get
inducted back in the matrix like i think
there's going to be a lot about that
steak scene
i think you know the experience of
chewing steak again the experience of
living again i also think we're living
in a time where this was made in a 20 it
was probably made in 2018 2019 or
written then to be to be released now
we're going to be commenting on what
it's like to experience things again
that's going to feel very topical and
timely where he's been outside of the
matrix in the cold eating wheaties so
he's going to be experiencing life anew
but feeling like it's not correct so i
think there's going to be a lot of
elements of what it's like to be
reprogrammed as a people which we kind
of are going to need to be after this
year this is obviously the most serious
i've ever taken any trailer
that's like that action man like london
wachowski directed all of this and
including no second unit like that's all
yeah lana there's like a super
impressive okay well this is going to be
different because there's no lily
wachowski this time around and on top of
that too lot of wachowski writing with
two other writers as well which is very
different than the the first three
matrix films so this has a different
vibe to it and a different aesthetic and
a whole lot of symbolism throughout i
guess one thing too that i'm just
believed about is i thought maybe it
would be neil just be like a supporting
character when they redid this i'm like
oh i'm so glad to see he's the main
character again yeah
you know he just shows up he's like i'll
teach you how to fly i was like it's
like how much of a reboot was this going
to be so i guess the big question i
can't i'm putting we're putting all
these theories together but a big
question i can't figure out is why
they've rebooted the matrix i mean
obviously that as we learn from matrix
reloaded the matrix is rebooted all the
time this is the seventh version of the
matrix that we're watching here so that
it has to be rebooted what's gonna make
this entirely different but i'm liking
like the self-discovery of how like
there's these action scenes where it
doesn't look like he's fully honed in on
his powers of the one but he's like
they're slowly coming back to him yeah i
think there's gonna be a fair amount of
like that pivot shot where it goes from
horizontal up to vertical and then we
track and push through yeah i feel like
there's gonna be a lot of scenes where
we're actually going between realities
like as we reboot and re-enter whichever
reality in world we're in i think it's
going to be a really big element of the
film and i'm curious if we get any
scenes that are of the old aesthetic
yeah are we going to have that old green
sheep first film has where it immerses
us in the version one or four of the
matrix i mean there are there are like
things with the production design like
sometimes with the rain effects which
rain has been very symbolic with having
like the matrix code in there yeah one
shot i think he was looking at trinity
where it seemed like he could see the
code ruger yeah
one guy that i think was an agent and
that flashes in the opening he had the
code in his eyes i imagine that as he
becomes more accepting of the world that
uh he is inhabiting neo i would imagine
that the cinematography color palette
like we were talking about would change
how while he's in blue pill world he is
that's the second thing that john's
talking about yes and then when he's as
he's going down the red pill round
you know uh then eventually which
because yeah right now like it doesn't
have that green aesthetic that i'm used
to and that's an interesting commentary
in general the saturation being the
flavor metaphor i was talking about the
steak and then the desaturation of the
cold world of zion the question is is it
better is ignorance bliss are we going
back to like do we want to be part of
something that isn't technically real i
just want to do or to appreciate i just
want to do it let's do a live stream
let's do a live show
is it worth living if it's cold and dark
and you're just eating that awful sludge
is it worth it i could talk about this
forever
obviously you're not gonna be able to
shut coin eye up unless you just end the
video guys
i just paused for you grace i paused for
you john subscribe i mean if you guys
keep going you'll get any thought i
would have yeah
i wouldn't have noticed the blue as much
someone knows i disagree sorry i
disappeared
subscribe
we're very huge experience
i nothing else with this movie and now
it's here all right guys make sure to
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and please follow koi on his
youtube channel he's obviously earned a
subscribe button from you guys and hey
we'll catch you guys soon
you